course truly a busy spot this fourth of
july this year there is some added
intrigue that's right visitors from all
over are coming to our lake seeing these
low water levels are revealing our david
torrance takes us there
this is where that body in a barrel was
found two months ago now and you can see
just how much of the lake has receded
since then that was the shore here we
are now but knowing that more bodies
could be in the lake isn't stopping
anyone from getting
in and this is the lowest i've seen it
visitors to the lake like mark graham
from california say seeing the water
level decline so fast is shocking
saddening from what i've seen it in the
past the lake's past oddly dotting its
present clothing furniture bottles and
cans you name it you can find it what
was once under water just days ago is
now new beach news of a body discovered
in a barrel in may and then more
skeletal remains found a week later
bringing hunters to these shores after
years and years of people just
indiscriminately throwing things in the
water and
falling and all kinds of odd things you
know you're sure to come you know find
things that aren't going to be very
sightly it's sad to see it go down it is
tim welch lives in the area he says he
goes out on the lake frequently yeah
every time we come out here it's part of
the conversation is look at how low it
is we look and we see some stuff that's
going on some changes those celebrating
this independence day thinking about
this national park and the environment
it's extremely
sad to say the least it's kind of tragic
to see the water levels decrease to be
honest park ranger is reminding
everybody if you do find something you
have to call them you cannot take
anything from the lake because it's
considered an artifact we're near lake
mead i'm david charns live local now